I hope this hasn't gotten too mathy for
you wonderful biology students out there, but I want
to throw one more big, cool calculation on
you. One way of actually measuring or estimating heritability
is to compare the correlation of a trait
between monozygotic twins and dizygotic twins. Now there are
multiple equations out there that people use to
estimate or calculate heritability. One of the one's that's
relevant to what we've learned so far,
is using the correlations between monozygotic and dizygotic
twins for trait. And this is the
equation here. Heritability is equal to two times
the monozygotic correlation minus the dizygotic correlation.
Now the chief assumptions here are that monozygotic
twins Are twice as genetically identical as dizygotic
twins, right? Dizygotic twins are 50% identical and
monozygotic twins are 100% genetically identical. And that's
where this two comes in outside the parenthesis.
Because monozygotic twins are twice as identical, or
two times as identical as dizygotic twins. So if
our heritability is low, if it's under 0.5.
It means that variation in the trait reflect
environmental influences because the dizygotic correlation roughly equal
the monozygotic correlation. So we're getting a much lower
number from our equation. But if variation chiefly reflects
genetic influences, then the correlation between monozygotic twins is
going to be much higher than dizygotic twins. So we're
going to get a much higher heritability value. So let's
look at the heritability of a trait like height.
So here we have a monzygotic correlation of 0.95
and a dizygotic correlation of 0.525. So if we
plug these numbers into our equation we get a heritability
of 0.85. And this is actually the heritability of height
in developed countries. Does this mean that the environment or the
genome plays a larger role in determining the variability of the
trait of height. Use this heritability value to decide your response.